yeah expression when he is a Korean
zombie where is he he just well he
served in the military for two years
like a good Korean citizen that's a good
movie for you and I was that two guys
you were born you and I were born in
Korea but we came back we were raised
United States but then we go through we
go back to serve in the military right
two years - hear me out for two years
but that's when the war breaks out right
so me and you know two stoners me what
just you it's a movie it's a movie do
you in the movie scared why cuz I don't
know this would've grateful that I'm not
in Korea to go to military like the a
mandatory like oh my god like that dude
imagine him because he would grow up in
North Korea though yeah so imagine him
at the DMZ will you be skinny though I'd
be different you be so different you
grew up different you'd be so yeah your
mentality is different everything's
different
I feel like you would be like the worst
I don't know maybe I can get next to the
guy you're like you know you're crazy
enough where you could be next to me you
know right let me ask you this if you
and I were both DMZ soldiers okay
Melbourne North Korean and we were
against we're on the wall you know we're
the guys standing yeah okay and I turn
to you and I say hmm and I run into the
other side yeah we shoot me
hell no be real I don't think so I would
I would act like I was I would like you
know they do they shoot like yeah [ __ ]
over masterís he'll get in trouble yes
but I definitely let you go anybody even
people that are like half as but jeez oh
so you plan it I got I'm gonna run but
you pretend you shoot you're right these
like shoot him in the shoulder but make
sure you know what do you see on the
shoulder just to make sure that you
don't lose your job or they suspect that
you were in on it just like any time
like I've seen like when some of the
gear you have to kill this person and
that's their friend well I've been in
situations like that so they're like
they just miss a bad shot I'm sorry I
missed right I think you take out an
ankle yeah I know what I would do
he can't run these [ __ ] what if he would
have been what if it's deep in the you
know how those North Korea I mean I'm
sorry that's a bug South Korean soldiers
in the line they're looking for
defectors right so they actually help
out like that dude who went on a car
chase and then he started running and he
had been shot five times the South
Korean soldiers they [ __ ] went in and
they dragged his ass out of there like
they're looking to help so if you just
shoot one ankle I think that you know
the guys will come forward and I would
if I was he said I'm gonna run I'm gonna
pretend right so he's gonna run out
actually shoot him yeah because then I
can go I to Kim Jong moon I did it I get
it for you maybe I'll get some extra
[ __ ] like be on the board maybe I could
get a better government job or something
maybe what if you just get like one Cod
me dinner that's it
or I would be oh maybe if you did it a
couple of times it's here that's how
easily I am I would do things so I can
gain favor that's who I am because you
might get torture to death a little bit
but not too too bad that like your ear
you're not irredeemable no I think that
I would weasel my way to the top of any
structure just out of survival that
sucks
and would you survive at least you're
honest about it would you accost your
friendships and like your connections
with the people that you love for the
sake of like reaching them no no no not
my family like I would never [ __ ] over
my brother I would never [ __ ] over my
parents my wife you know I mean but I
would [ __ ] over Gilbert [ __ ] you over
yeah I would [ __ ] over like Pauly Shore
in in a North Korean situation oh yeah
yeah so you talk over your outer
concentric circles in your life yeah
super family yeah like if I was working
for Schindler
okay good right no you know what I
probably wouldn't say anything I think
it'll be one of those guys
Zama gage I'm good I'm good in a
prison-like situation you're a snitch
and if you got if you knew your sentence
was gonna get shortened like you you're
you're not an allied to anybody you're
an ally to the system Emily you're now
lied to yourself and that's it which is
fine because you're a survivor
yeah isn't the point though in the life
to survive no sometimes it's to be part
of a brotherhood and to stick by that by
that you know I don't want to die like
in a prison situation it's like I help
this guy out I'm gonna die and I want to
live it's self-preservation does that
make me a bad guy
no just makes you a horrible friend yeah
you're still a good guy kind of a bad
guy kind of yeah what do you mean I
don't know like in like in um let's do a
movie um yeah I think that I mean that
guy in the Mafia movie is that like we
like I'm resolved yeah I'm in the court
like in court like
you're the rat I'm the rat like it good
fellows hmm
remember when the kid when the kid
didn't testify and he got like props
from that yeah you know you would have
told I don't know you would have died
then